the votes for Sunday's Toni's awards are
waiting to be counted but judges from
the American Theatre Wing the Broadway
League and Carnegie Mellon University
have already selected a teacher to take
home the Tony Award for Excellence in
theater education and this year's winner
is drumroll please Rachel Harry from
Hood River Oregon Jaime whack shows us
what inspires her to make an impact on
her students on and off the stage its
campus Pride Day at Oregon's Hood River
Valley High School there's music ice
cream and an assembly to recognize a
favorite teacher and I get the distinct
pleasure to ask Miss Harry to join me on
stage but before we go on with the
celebration let's see what led Rachael
Harry to this moment I just remember
that everybody's holding a pose for a
very long time affectionately known as
crumb she's been showing theater
students how to find their mark you just
have to tease it and light a stage for
31 years and what led you to teaching
theater in high school specifically I
love teenagers I love everything they're
going through the drama she's gonna come
out and strike a pose they come in as
these basically kids and they leave as
adults she really changes people's lives
and that's that's incredible
students agree she's much more than a
teacher she's definitely a mother figure
she's created a second home
and she's made me feel more comfortable
in my own skin I think I can't imagine
what it would have been like growing up
outside of here Taylan is a former
student and one of crumbs two children
she never wanted us far from her so it
we were never very far from the theatre
of all of the lessons that she's given
you as a mother
and as a teacher what's the most
important thing you take away from your
mother oh my gosh uh you are the most
important person everyone is the most
important person to themselves
before Crum took to the stage as a
teacher she had other plans I wanted to
be a dancer and I went to University of
Utah as a ballet major and I loved
dancing all day but I didn't really fit
but I fit in with the theater kids are
you saying I'm a dinosaur
I would never watching you work with
your kids you're extremely collaborative
you are an artist asking them to
collaborate with you and your vision
their hands-on they want to get up and
move they want to do things I'm the same
way
she teaches us in a way that we don't
feel like we're being patronized or you
know talked down to strong teachers are
often a beacon in and out of the
classroom that's good and sometimes
they'll need to rely on that strength
themselves in 2006 you went through a
really yeah here yeah that was that was
bad she faced divorced and a cancer
diagnosis at once I said you know I'm
looking at this as a giant huge
teachable moment how does someone cope
with cancer and the kids were sorry the
kids were awesome you remember watching
your mother go through that I do because
I was a freshman in high school so I was
here for a lot of it
my brother and I shaved all her hair off
she never showed a sign of weakness she
just kept going my teaching is my art is
Who I am
there were people's and well you need to
you know you're gonna have to take time
off from work and I was going I can't
don't ask me to do that please because
this is my life this is my world more
than ten years later and Crum is still
feeling her community's love support and
on this day recognition from the Tony
Awards for excellence in theatre
education you were selected as the
educator of the year congratulations
we surprised her with the news in front
of her students and she couldn't leave
the stage without offering all of us
another lesson I had to work really hard
and lots of times I felt like giving up
but I didn't so you guys keep at it
follow your dreams okay will you do that
for me I love all of you thank you and
as you can see they love her right back
really a remarkable and dedicated
teacher
Rachel Harry will receive her Tony Award
during the broadcast and her school's
theater department gets ten thousand
dollars and I got to tell you there is
no star we are more excited to see on
the red carpet Sunday all right look I
can tell by the way she sits in the
chair
very funky haircut that she is something
she is a true artist I would say said
she loves teenagers yes I and I do
believe teaching really saved her life
after meeting good-looking first Monday
night yeah
Jamie thank you and you can watch the
71st annual Tony Awards this Sunday
night at 8:00 7:00 central that's right
here on CBS this